so one of the symptoms in my life that i
know i'm miserable and covet and really
it's a symptom of how
how far i've sunk is i become excite
obsessed with the 90-day fiance reality
fist bump obsessed oh my god i can't get
enough and that's a sick
symptom oh yeah but as a result of many
many hours of viewing of that
hazerai is that what you do yeah
um i uh i've learned about other
cultures in this male female stuff
that's crazy how about the african guy
oh my god in his culture
hold on you need to bow down to the man
take care of what they call submissive
yeah and she's like
and she goes i'm american it ain't
happening i'm telling you right now it
ain't going to go down
they casted that perfectly this is the
best hey i want to i want to point out
your boy soldier boy is it a new season
no you're gonna we'll sit down and watch
it with you sometimes it's so good to do
a viewing party
because we have our own pillow talks
that's a great idea come on man i'll
watch a couple episodes i love it yeah
and like
because she's like traditional south and
she's like very like
women-powered and then he's you straight
from like kenya or nigeria i forget
where nigeria nigerian yeah and there
it's like the woman
who stays at home takes care of the man
oh yeah yeah yeah food you know
all the elders in the family the females
are like well of course you'll submit to
him and she's like
i'll do what she's like this is over
she's like i'm a marriage she's a damn
dixie chick she sounds like one of the
darkest dixie kids they're just dicks
yeah yeah they're not they're just dixie
now
thank you so much for jumping in today
and you'll be great yeah
you'll be great you got it you're fine
yeah you're fine yeah you're really fine
but i'm with drew your best friends are
crazy well you just be careful that's
all just know
see look at their motivation that's and
i do think men and women can be great
friends that's not my thing at all
but sometimes harbor people harbor a
little desire behind that yeah you're
right i've
i've loved being married because of that
that has been a great female friend that
has been a great gift i have legitimate
female friends because my motives aren't
no really granted yeah oh yeah do they
look like warlocks no no no no like like
katie ellis jason's
katie ellis is [ __ ] fine and if i was
single
it would be weird if i was her friend
now especially because jason's wife
like like it's well your buddy's wife
like dr drew's wife but even like my
wife's
my wife's friends who are oftentimes
actresses and [ __ ] and they're like
[ __ ] crazy hot like i love the
ability
i'm saying you meet a girl at a coffee
shop i'm not making friends with her
that's what i'm saying too dangerous if
it's your buddy's girlfriend or
or wife then you can be friends with
them right but if it's just an outsider
and she's single yeah but even girls
like co-workers that are attractive
like now i feel really comfortable like
being like asking just talking having
conversations
engaging in that way because yeah i'm
not my motives aren't the same you know
like i like that too as i
i think some of that's also just as i
get a little bit older i'm just able to
recognize like you don't have to try to
be sexual towards any woman who just
kind of shows you attention
or you don't all you know sometimes it's
just going to be a bad idea
well it's like it's like cat you know
cat's probably my best one of my best
female friends she's a single
24 year old you know i i i don't
look at i don't even it's almost like
she's this little sister
right right but i will say this with
younger girls now though
um and i mean obviously legally aged
humans i'm glad you said that you bet
yeah uh you're bad
but um i definitely get more
scared now of even talking to a girl
probably that's what imagine you're 27
you know me you're 25. oh how scared
you'd be
oh i can't even imagine so yeah
well hey good times i just don't want to
do anything what's your favorite episode
of 90 day fiance yeah uh oh i like the
one when uh humble he's like russian or
something
and they fly all the way from the
moldova to boldova
and they get there and the fiance and
the dude then the brother about the
fight
they're in there he's like we'll go out
he goes we'll go outside i'll show you
because he has like a sketchy pass
they're like why were you in dublin yeah
why are we in ireland
and he's like please just stop with the
questions they keep picking at him and
then finally he's like shut up
the first time he's meaning and i see
the evil hand of producers behind a lot
of it too they're just
pouring the alcohol yeah there's a lot
of alcohol and then they both stand up
they're about to straight up
fight it's fantastic i love that do you
think there should be any repercussions
to some of these production companies
that are just pouring gas into people
reality tv i understand that i
understand that
it's not though theo's onto something
you're looking at it from a seasoned
not only a professional athlete but a
guy who has grinded in the entertainment
industry and you've
you've developed a kind of a maturity in
it yes imagine if
you're from theo's hometown you're 19 20
you come to la
and some [ __ ] exploitive disgusting
producer comes and they're like
it's gonna be great go on the
bachelorette you're gonna be awesome
and then they pour alcohol down your
face and then and you're having this
existential thing on set and they go
we're going to talk to you
you're totally right for hating that guy
right because and they've so
i've had that so watch when i first got
here that's my childhood watch
watch this scripted series unreal
because that is the that is an
accurate portrayal of how it goes down
and if you still want to do it then it's
on they're adults it's on them yeah you
know people kind of know what to do
what's interesting because when i was
young we had um or when i was young
enough you know
to be 19 we had um
you they hadn't had reality television
out there yeah they only had a few years
of it sure
so it wasn't just rules yeah road rules
in real world like that was it so you
would you could go into
reality tv as a contestant or as a cast
member
and be yourself still you weren't savvy
to the game
right now like nor were the producers
yes they weren't upping they weren't
upping the game the same way
agreed it was different i remember a lot
of it is casting a lot of how they cast
but i had no idea what they're doing at
night we would spend time playing
somebody who
had an instrument there were people
there that were doctors that were
uh that are now politicians that were
just spending their you know spending a
two week or
a month period taking out from their
lives and at night we'd sit around a
campfire it was a little different
and then it escalated to where it was
just there be no milk but there would be
tequila but even on the ultimate fighter
it's like you know you have this list
every
every night you give the list the next
morning the food would come if we asked
for
you know burger meat or chicken breast
it would come you know maybe by midday
if we asked for alcohol
it would be there that night right so
the alcohol part is the part i've been
concerned about and to some extent i'm
being a bit
um facetious and saying that the
producers were forcing the alcohol
it was probably some local moldovan film
crew let's face it
provided and then it's provided and they
weren't really drinking that much
i think they backed off that i think i
think people understand that they
that that's not cool but here's what i
don't like maybe in some of the mpv
but here's what i don't like about it
there's an inconsistency and you and i
both know this firsthand yeah
because in one way they take reality
innocent reality tv stars
yeah i know they're adorable but they're
still they're still just normal humans
and they put them in the in the pit of
fire and they push it a heightened
situation
they also at the same time television
producers
overly protect politicians and
established entertainers you know when
we would have to do an interview with
fill in the blank politician
or or a big celebrity there's like this
is exactly what you can and can
ask this is exactly what you can't topic
you can't even go into this
and uh make sure that there is this and
this on set or else we're not showing up
and so there's an inconsistency where
they're taking the average joe and the
average jane
and they're [ __ ] with them as much as
possible but yet overly protecting the
people that we
probably most need to get to the bottom
well like i have a buddy who did a thing
on a large network we all know and it
was a competition comedy thing
and he went out there and crushed it and
crushed it and gets back and they go
you know man with your childhood would
your uh dead
you know father and uh friend what what
would are they here and he's like
what like and they keep praying he's
like oh this isn't about comedy at
all yeah you guys are trying to paint
this narrative it's a reality show and
he
he's not savvy doing it at all and he's
like no i just crushed on stage i'm good
man i'm not thinking about my dad or my
dead friend
i'm thinking about beating in this
competition he didn't get selected
because they're not going to play the
game they're not going to be
even though he's the best comic by far
there they didn't pick him because he
wouldn't play the game
i thought i think who ate [ __ ] but had
some childhood trauma and talked about
it
but the interesting thing i also know
i'm just it up the kind of the point i
was making i'm slow to get to points
because i don't know sometimes what i'm
exactly gonna talk about but i'm saying
this is that
um now people grow up watching enough
reality tv that when they get to a show
that they're on
they already have a character that
they're going to be
with it's almost like it's just it's
it's so it's so bizarre
cartoons well look look at the real
housewives
the real housewives man you watch the
real housewives and it's insane
i told you dawg [ __ ] vg though
back back to one of the earlier points
we're talking about is how people make
an assumption about a certain part of
the country
if you watch beverly hills housewives
you think that's how people are in
beverly hills if you watch the hills you
think that's how people are in l.a
you watch jersey shore you think that's
how dirt and it's like dude i lived in
jersey for two years
some of the most [ __ ] educated
thoughtful people and it's like
but they love to create this idea that
it's all guidos they love to create the
idea that everyone
in the south is this [ __ ] toothless
racist and it's like
dude what are we doing you gotta
remember that what that humans
the whole nature of drama i mean what
did sophocles write about right
sick people acting sick all drama is
that
humans are drawn to the narratives of
other humans
engaged in extreme and usually
pathological behaviors
yeah we don't you know a healthy family
sitting down at dinner we don't watch
that
hell no that's boring chaos but they
can't be striking each other in the head
and throwing spaghetti and stuff
we're in we're not we're going to watch
just in the human
on a much higher scale yeah because
sometimes it's like are we are we
actually creating bad stuff or are we
just creating exactly what
we really want no it's it the the market
decides and
and and there is where we have
uh the consumer is to blame too because
it goes it goes into a more important
level too
how many stories are you going to see on
cnn or in the new york times about a cop
who [ __ ] risks his life to go into a
burning building to save a family or a
cop who
who dives in front of an open fire you
know any news it doesn't it doesn't and
that
[ __ ] [ __ ] happens a lot i've watched
with my own eyes i've watched cops spend
all day trying to counsel [ __ ] crazy
homeless people in venice i watch it
well that's
what happened way more often than the
other stuff within the stuff
but news has become a reality show
narrative although it has it's
all wwe it's all turned into wrestling
yeah their narratives are their
narratives they stick with those
narratives
my wife said but tell them you just come
on our podcast stream or whatever
i want to sorry so maybe we'll do that
why don't we watch the show i need to
catch up on the show
beyonce and do a pillow talk hello where
should we do it it's a fantastic idea
where should we stream
don't get sued calling it pillow talk
yeah well you have way more bedrooms
than
that i don't think i don't think they
own the name pelotok they have a show on
no i'm aware i see it all the time but
it'd be weird and by the way we're
making
it's an homage to them yeah yeah yeah by
the way the pillow talk part is my
wife's favorite part of the night
i prefer it over that right who's your
favorite couple oh i like the couple
who's in florida the
the he's he's super jewish he's our
israeli
israeli yeah they have a new baby they
have the new babies yes
this is so cool oh and and i love the
real fat guy in the
thai girl oh super the guy head yeah
yeah oh a little weird yeah beautiful
little fella and he's doing cameo you
know what though
he he's he he keeps his sense of humor
about all of it god bless him
god bless him oh have you watched the
the twins new
spin-off yeah i've been subjected to
that that's all i think
i talk all day about reality shows
nick those are some of the hottest shows
aren't they those covered shows yeah i
uh they're huge the ones just recapping
reality shows or
actually do one yeah let's do it drew
okay fiance would be a great one because
you guys could do it in a series
i'll come do so a couple of episodes
because i'll just be a guest but you
guys could do it i mean i'll do it
we should all do it it'll be great i'm
in i mean it'd be fun to sit and talk
about that
it's so fun it's so entertaining man and
if you guys were just watching it and
pausing
like it could be really low time
investment too it doesn't have to be
like
yeah like we could do a few a whole
whole series of them in different shows
it'd be interesting if we all watched it
even whether we did some of it together
or separate and then just recorded
ourselves watching it and commented it
oh that's good like a reality like a
video and then we add that
into it yeah when we're all together and
here's ed and brittany greiner right
here
[Music]
he's got a little cross there yeah he
has trouble
with the jab done he doesn't he can't
quite pull his shoulder up high enough
oh that dude's eating a lot of jabs bro
huh a lot of what
you guys you guys do pillow talk on 90
day fiance we'll do pillow talk about
like browsers
or something no no no
dude i'm i'm out i bet we could get
these people on too
of course you could easily now i want to
do that love on the spectrum autism love
man that's what it is
i started with that i started with that
and and i don't
i personally said something up for me
you didn't like it i'll tell you what i
don't like i don't like the
sanctimonious british
and the talk of spoke the the they're
australian
whatever it is it's just it's just
here's a soft spoken [ __ ] i just i
hate it i hate it
all right so i can't i can't it's too
distracting for me what i liked was the
indian matchmaker
we got to do that one too michael
and i happen to be a 25 year old man
he's great yeah i'll tell you what you
are going to get
a grade a husband
i love that guy yeah i love him too well
maybe we'll have a new show starting up
[ __ ] yeah that's a good idea mike andrew
thank you guys
[Music]